let's go to dean from dallas texas dean
you're on the air save us please dean
hi can you hear me yes i can
hi uh first time caller long time
listener um i wanted to ask
uh do you think with the ongoing
pandemic having a massive impact uh
mostly on the elderly when it comes to
fatalities
that there will be a significant
extension to social security seeing as
how
you know more and more people are buying
in and
you know they won't be able to uh
to cash it to cash out i'm not sure i
know what you're talking about you're
will social security be extended what do
you mean
yeah like um
the estimations for when social security
runs out of money oh i see oh so are you
are you saying is the money gonna last
longer or are people gonna have to wait
longer before they can start getting
social security right right is the money
gonna last longer
for uh you know because it's projected
that people like me on the younger side
won't be able to even collect because
it'll long run out of money by then
listen though those predictions are
heavily disputed so but i wouldn't even
necessarily start with that as the
expectation of where we are that that
there are many serious analyses done of
the social security trust fund which say
it it's it's not going to run out
there there may need to be a period
during which people pay in a little more
or during which they might get out a
little less or have to wait an extra
year some but the the it's gonna all run
out hypotheses my understanding is have
been pretty widely debunked um in terms
of the effect of covet on that i don't
know the answer to that it's a very good
question but i think it's it's something
that it has it's got to be studied by
experts in that field and i don't know
that we're going to have all the data
until we're really out of the pandemic
right right well thanks for taking my
call appreciate it my pleasure
appreciate the call yeah that's that's a
really interesting question
uh i wish i had an answer i wish i had
an answer but i don't
let's go next to jack from indianapolis
indiana jack you are on the air
uh hey david how are you i'm doing well
so um
i've just kind of been looking at the
way things have been going in um in
america right now yeah and um
you know the thing about it is that it
can get kind of depressing
um and i think like
you know why do i follow this stuff so
much if you know all i can do is vote i
mean
aside from that also do some music that
is about these issues like police
brutality and government corruption
stuff like that but
i was curious as to if you had any um
recommendations as far as like uh i
think they called civic engagement
you're saying what can you do other than
voting is that more or less what you're
saying
basically yeah
there are so many things i mean listen
first of all
with technology the way it is now
you can participate in essentially any
race you want to by phone banking and
fundraising remotely if that's what
you're interested in doing that that's
number one
number two
really important to understand that you
don't have to attach your activism to
individuals you might attach your
activism excuse me to issues
there might be you know regardless of
who your senator is
at the local level where you live
you could figure out oh you know what
there's a conservation commission in my
city or town i'm gonna get involved in
that or if you care about literacy
most libraries and library systems have
ways for you to get involved i think the
first thing is
we've got to kind of disabuse ourselves
of this notion that there aren't that
many different ways that that we can get
involved there's community radio and
community television where you can get
involved essentially at no cost
depending on where you live in most
parts of the country um
there there's really so much and so the
first it's almost like there's there's
too much and you've got to figure out do
i want to work locally or at the state
level do i want to work by helping a
candidate or do i want to work on an
issue what do i care about most
education the environment et cetera
there really is no shortage of ways to
get involved
okay
yeah that makes sense um what what
exactly is phone
phone banking is very simple you base
there's now there's systems where let's
say um you know let's say it's john
fetterman versus mehmet oz in the
pennsylvania senate race and it's a few
months from now right it's the 2022
election even if you don't live in
pennsylvania
you can sign up to phone bank and
basically you can sit at your computer
and you'll get it'll pop up and it'll
say okay here is a believed democratic
voter call them ask them if they're
planning to vote um call and it's so so
you can it's basically all done through
software at this point and no matter
where you are you can start making phone
calls for any candidate you want most
candidates assuming that they're set up
with these phone banking systems
okay that makes sense yeah really easy
yeah i think that's about it thanks for
uh having me on my pleasure here yeah
engagement so many ways to get involved
there's really no shortage no shortage
um it's almost an embarrassment of rich
of riches quite frankly
let's go next to
i believe
is it pronounced vedant from is it
winnipeg i'm not even sure
yeah can you hear me yes i can
how are you doing mr pacman i'm doing
well
yeah so winnipeg we're just in manitoba
canada love it
yeah so um my question was about how do
you choose what to cover because i'll
preface this with i listen to a lot of
like the new media landscape a lot of
breaking points with crystal and sauger
kyle kalinski tyt stuff like that as
well as yourself
and i find that
um like for example tyt will focus a lot
on like donations from
big um
like companies into politicians and how
that runs the political landscape i've
noticed that you find it tend to focus a
little more on like january 6 stuff like
that and i was wondering what makes you
find that that's the most important
thing that you want to cover it's not
this is a beautiful question vedant how
old how old a guy are you by the way i
am 15. okay i had a feeling you were a
younger guy listen you are asking really
high level questions here okay you oh
you i i think you have upper management
written all over you as we like to say
in the united states
here's some here's the bottom line
um i don't have any
secret algorithm or anything
about what i'm going to cover i get to
cover eight stories a day more or less
and basically what i think about is what
do i feel like talking about today
where do i have something to add on a
story
what does my audience what might my
audience be interested in hearing about
um and is it time sensitive and
newsworthy and if so i just kind of say
here's the eight things i want to talk
about today i have all these different
possibilities and i'm looking at you
know i have a list of journalists i
follow on twitter and i'm all sorts of
newsletters and it's basically just what
do i want to share with my audience
today that's really it the reason for me
talking about january 6th significantly
because you mentioned that
is
the right is trying to rewrite history
on what happened there i think it's an
incredibly
important sort of before and after event
that has kind of changed the direction
of what we thought the right was willing
to do or maybe thought they were not
willing to do and i want to do
everything i can to remind people that
really wasn't normal we still haven't
gotten a full understanding of
everything that happened on that day so
that's why like in the last 10 days or
so i've been talking about it a lot to
answer that specifically
okay that makes a lot of sense and then
this one's just a little more of a fun
one but like i was wondering like what
do you think about canada have you been
up here if so like what places do you
visit i love canada i have to say
the overwhelming majority of my
experience is in montreal i've been to
montreal probably 20 times in my life i
grew up going there and i've been i've
been so many times i love it i've been
to toronto
it had less charm but a beautifully
organized kind of
less european city if that makes sense
you know it's a different story i've
also been to ottawa once
i i i don't want to insult ottawa but i
remember very little about it it did not
uh inspire me in in any real way and um
i'm really i've never been to quebec
city but i would like to go as soon as
it's uh reasonable and safe but i i love
canada and in particular you know i'm a
big i love france and so going to quebec
i just enjoy it significantly i'm sure
i'm sure i went for the first time this
summer just to move my brother into
college and that was really nice oh okay
what mcgill
miguel yeah mcgill is great mcgill's
great that's uh that's fantastic well
listen um is the correct pronunciation
vedant
it's vedant they don't and what are the
origins of that name um so it means
eternal knowledge in sanskrit so my
family is originally from tamil nadu
which is the southernmost province of
india amazing amazing well listen i uh i
appreciate the call my friend thank you
so much have a great rest of your day
alright you do wow what a polite young
man folks what a polite young man that
is that is really something else